let us now bow our heads as we pray father
in heaven in the time left to your manservant
grant me the words grant me the right spirit open
the hearts of your people who have come to listen
let the truth spoken find a welcome in their
hearts that when we leave we may leave rejoicing
in the truth and your name alone glorified i
offer this prayer in jesus name and for his sake
amen let me urge you and encourage
you to come back tonight because
what i say now i will say much more in the
evening for the obvious reason i have more time
our subject is what and where is the kingdom
of god what and where is the kingdom of god
when adam sinned he turned over
dominion of this world to someone else
when god said let us make man in our image after
our likeness and let them have dominion over the
fish of the sea fall of the air god gave dominion
not ownership but dominion the world was put
under adam psalm 8 reading from verse 3 when i
consider thy heavens the works of thy fingers
the moon and the stars which thou hast ordained
what is man that thou art mindful of him
and the son of man that thou visites him for
thou has made him a little lower than the angels
and has cranked him with glory and honor thou
givers him to have dominion over the works of
thy hands thou has put all things under his feet
all things under his feet simply meant that adam
was in charge of the created world in which god
put him to live mankind was given dominion over
the world not ownership because god is very clear
the earth is the lord's and the fullness thereof
the world and they that dwell therein when
melchizedek bless abram in genesis 14 verse 20
verse 19 he said blessed be abram of the most high
god possessor of heaven and earth it belongs to
god but he has give he gave dominion but when adam
sinned he lost the dominion and so when the devil
tempted jesus christ according to luke's version
in luke chapter 4 verse 5-7 the bible says and the
devil taking him up into a high mountain showed
him all the kingdoms of the world in a moment of
time and the devil said unto him all this power
will i give unto thee and the glory of them
for that is delivered unto me and to whomsoever
i will give it the devil says that has been
delivered unto me he was referring to the fact
that when adam fell adam delivered dominion
over to him now the bible does acknowledge the
devil has some dominion not ownership because
jesus in john 12 31 says now is the judgment of
this world now shall the prince of this world
be cast out in john 14 30 jesus says henceforth
i will not talk much with you for the prince of
this world cometh and hath nothing in me in second
corinthians chapter 4 verse 4 paul says because
the god of this world has blinded their minds
so the devil is regarded as the prince of this
world the god of this world but when jesus died on
calvary he reclaimed the dominion that adam lost
i've just given you a lot rapid fire because
of little time let me repeat it when god made
adam he gave him dominion you are responsible for
this world vegetation the animals the environment
adam sinned and he forfeited that dominion to the
devil and the devil had some kind of legal right
because the one who was in charge submitted to
his rule and we're told in second peter chapter
2 verse 19 by whom a man is overcome of the same
is he brought in bondage adam was overcome by the
devil and of course he came under the devil's rule
in the sense that satan became the prince of this
world christ reclaimed that dominion when he died
on earth now when god made the earth it was god's
intention to extend his kingdom his reign of love
upon this earth life on this earth was to be a
reflection of life in the kingdom above adam was
supposed to be the the leader in making sure that
things were done according to the standards
of the kingdom of god this was god's will to
extend his reign and his rule it is a reign of
love and a reign of law the united states has
some sort of foreign policy to extend democracy
all over the world whether people want it or not
that's the policy spread democracy all right god's
policy is spread the kingdom of love that's why he
made the heaven and the earth adam's saying the
devil took over now god called a special people
and i'm jumping from genesis to exodus they were
the descendants of abraham they're the israelites
they were in egypt slaves god has delivered
them and now they are in the wilderness and
god tells moses in exodus chapter 25 verse
8 and let them make me a sanctuary why
that i might what dwell among them it has always
been god's desire to dwell with his people
the christian in times of human loneliness must
ever understand that god dwells with me and i'm
not speaking symbolically symbolically i'm
speaking quite literally god dwells with us
in the person of his holy spirit and the angels
that we cannot see that surround us and protect us
god said let them make me a sanctuary that
i might dwell among them exodus 25 verse 8.
even before adam sinned god would come down and
talk to him we must we can extrapolate that from
verse 9 which says and they heard the voice of
the lord god walking in the garden of the cool
of the day actually verse 8 of genesis 3. so god
had a habit of coming down to talk with adam and
eve face to face dwelling with them interacting
socializing if that is the proper word to refer
to god's interaction with his people now he tells
the israelites through moses make me a sanctuary
that i might dwell among them the sanctuary which
was a tent because the word for sanctuary means
dwelling place a tent in john 1 14 where the bible
says and the word was made flesh and dwelt among
us the translation is tabernacled and it harks
back to the tabernacle in exodus 25 verse 8.
it was a tent with two compartments and we
know that what was the first compartment called
and the second compartment most holy place
the first compartment holy place the second
compartment most holy place then there was an
outer court where we had the altar of sacrifice
and the play and the liver and where the animals
were tied that were to be sacrificed in the holy
place there was a table of showbread to the north
there was the alt of incense and there was a seven
branch candelabrum or candlestick and in the most
holy place where the high priest could only go
once a year and if he entered that holy
place with sin in his life he dropped
dead and tradition tells us when he went into that
compartment a rope was tied around his waist and
there were bells on the hem of his garment as
the people listened to him ministering they can
hear the bells so they knew he was alive if they
ceased to hear the bells they knew he was dead
and they would use the rope to pull him
out because they could not go get him
you could not go into that most holy place
only the priest and only one day of the year
the day of atonement and he had to be sure all
his sins had been forgiven and cleansed now
in this most holy place there was one article of
furniture and that was called the what the ark
the ark was made of pure gold it was actually
thrown one there was a wooden frame a wooden box
overlaid and inlaid with gold exodus 25 verse
11. the dimensions were simple in verse 10
exodus 25 the bible says and they shall
make an ark of [ __ ] him wood two cubits
and a half shall be the length thereof one
cubit and a half the breast thereof and a
cubit and a half the height thereof and thou
shalt make thou shall ovulate with pure gold
within and without shalt thou ever lay and
shall place upon it a crown of gold round about
so we have this golden box and the purpose for
the box was to house what the ten commandments
and in verse 16 of exodus 25 the bible says
and thou shalt put into the ark the testimony
which i shall give thee in the ark out the ark was
the single most important article of furniture in
the tabernacle yeah indeed the whole point of the
tabernacle the whole point of all the sacrifices
was to make atonement for the violation of
god's holy law contained in that golden box
the ark may be properly referred to as the
very heart of the sanctuary and in it the
ten commandments the two tables of stone now the
ark had a lid called the mercy seat it was made
of gold verses 17 through 20 of exodus 25. and the
mercy seat covered the ark and god told moses in
verses 22 21 and 22 of exodus 25 that the the ten
commandments would go into the ark covered with
the mercy and in verse 22 god said and there i
will meet with thee right above the mercy seat
here's the here's the box the mercy seat is
the cover god said my presence will be right
upon or just above the mercy seat representing his
throne and god goes on to say and i'm there i will
meet with thee and i will commune with thee from
above the mercy sea from between the two cherubims
which are upon the ark of the testimony of all
things which i will give thee in commandment
unto the children of israel god is saying
whenever i speak i speak from this position
now if president clinton travels to indonesia
and he speaks where is he speaking from
when a sitting president goes anywhere in the
world and he speaks where is he speaking from
the white house
because he speaks with the authority of the ruler
of this republic he speaks with the authority of
the white house wherever he goes if condoleezza
rice the secretary of state if she goes to
siberia and she says anything she is speaking
with the authority of the white house
and so god says whatever i say i will say it
from here now that's not to mean that god did
god's presence wasn't seen anywhere else it
was seen at the door to the tabernacle of
the congregation meaning the holy place god's
presence was seen elsewhere but the authority
of his words they issued forth from that place
that represented his throne and this is the
picture we must understand when god speaks he
always speaks with the authority of his throne
so god speaks always as a
sovereign not as a negotiator
are you following me this is critical now
what's so critical about the throne of god
the ark represented the throne now in
the throne were the ten commandments
the foundation of god's throne is his law
let me say that again because i
didn't get an amen the first time
you're busy digesting i
understand let me try it again
the foundation of god's government of god's
kingdom of god's sovereignty is his law
in hebrews chapter 1 verse 8 by
the way read hebrews chapter 1
particularly from verses 4 on it's a remarkable
chapter that has god talking about jesus
and one of the things the father says about
the son verse 8 but unto the son he saith
thy throne o god is forever and ever a scepter
of righteousness is the scepter of thy kingdom
now what is a scepter a scepter is a staff that
symbolizes authority and rulership the father
says of jesus christ thy scepter a scepter of
righteousness is the scepter of thy kingdom
god's kingdom is administered on the principles of
righteousness the bible says all thy commandments
are righteousness we read in psalm 89 14 justice
and judgment are the habitations of thy throne
the word justice there could be translated
righteousness so righteousness and judgment are
the habitation of god's throne the word habitation
means foundation and the writer says that
because the foundation of the throne are the
ten commandments meaning that the kingdom of god
is a kingdom in which everything proceeds
on the basis of righteousness and judgment
as expressed incomparably in god's law his ten
commandments their commandments of righteousness
their commandments of justice and
jesus said their commandments of love
so we have the throne but let's take another
look at the throne what does throne mean
we said septa means a staff a symbol of authority
to rule the throne is no different when joseph
went to pharaoh to explain the two dreams that
pharaoh had after joseph explained the dreams
joseph took full advantage of the opportunity
of being in pharaoh's presence and he also told
pharaoh what to do now pharaoh didn't call him
to ask for what to do pharaoh just called for
the interpretation but when the christian has an
opportunity he makes the most of it am i right
so joseph told him what to do and pharaoh was so
impressed pharaoh put him in charge of the whole
country but one level under pharaoh here is what
pharaoh said to joseph in genesis 41 verse 40.
he said thou shalt be over my house
according unto thy word shall all my people
be ruled without exception then pharaoh being
a smart politician says only in the throne
will i be greater than thou
now he had just put joseph over his entire
kingdom but pharaoh understood that when
the buck had to stop it stopped at the
throne pharaoh said only in the throne
will i be greater than thou the throne there
is no higher level than the throne and this is
the position god occupies symbolically expressed
in the shekinah glory his presence that hovered
above the ark the ark representing his throne
now there is a throne in heaven that god occupies
and there are commandments in heaven now i can't
give precise details but i know from revelation
11 19 and the temple and the temple of god was
open in heaven and there was seen in his temple
the ark of the testament which is heaven's
version which was the original pattern on which
the earthly one was based you read exodus 25 verse
9 exodus 25 40. god told moses to make it based on
the pattern i will show you and the pattern he
received was the very original in heaven itself
which leads me to say this very quickly at 12 37
because that which was on the earth is just a copy
and not the original any man who wants to change
god's law is wasting time by changing the copy
where does he ask the way does he have to make his
change in the where's the original and who sits on
the throne now where are the ten commandments in
the throne now here comes some powerful earthling
he wants to change god's law and
i'm digressing as i always do
somehow he gets up to heaven and he goes into
god's presence and hears god on the throne
he wants to get at the law what does he
have to do move god what does satan say
i will ascend into heaven i will exalt my throne
above the stars of god i will sit also upon the
mount of the congregation in the sides of
the north i will ascend above the heights
of the clouds i will be like the most high to be
like god you've got to you see you cannot set up
a rival kingdom god will not allow that so you
either submit to god remove god because he sits
on the throne the foundation of which is his
righteous law now i'm asking the question what is
the kingdom of god and where is it the kingdom of
god is the rule of righteousness somebody say amen
now jesus said my kingdom is not of
this world that's what he told pilate
john 17 36 pilate said him in verse 35 am i a
jew thine own nation and the chief priests have
delivered thee unto me what hast thou done
verse 36 john 18 jesus answered my kingdom
is not of this world now jesus did not mean my
kingdom is not in this world he said my kingdom
is not of this world meaning my kingdom is not
earthly it is not worldly now it is in the world
but it's not worldly it is
on earth but it's not earthly
because he did say in luke 17 21
the kingdom of god is within you
in matthew 12 28 and luke 11 20 he said if i
cast out spirits devils by the spirit of god
the kingdom of god is come unto you the kingdom
of god came when jesus came john the baptist
matthew 3 verse 2 in those days came john
the baptist preaching in the wilderness of
judea and saying repent for the kingdom of
god is at hand the kingdom of god is here
jesus preached the same thing in matthew 14
17 and in mark chapter 1 verse 15 repent and
believe the gospel for the kingdom of god the
kingdom of heaven is here now it is not of the
world because its principles do not originate from
the world they originate from above that's what
jesus meant when he said my kingdom is not of this
world now he said the same thing of the disciples
in john 17 verse 14 jesus praying to his
father said i have given them thy word
and the world hath hated them because
they are not of the world even as i
am not of the world but while he was
saying that his disciples were on the earth
what did he mean verse 15 i pray not that
thou should take them out of the world but
thou should escape them from the evil the kingdom
of god is not tainted by the principles of evil
verse 16 john 17 they are not of the world even
as i am not of the world christians we need to
understand that the principles by which god
calls us to live our lives are not earthly
they are divine and god is not a professor who
sets you up for failure by presenting standards
that are contrary to your genetic makeup if god
calls earthlings to live by divine standards
he is morally compelled to provide the power to
allow earthlings to live up to divine standards
and so the kingdom of god is not of this world
in the sense that it is not of an earthly origin
it is heavenly but god tells us through the
power of jesus christ my heavenly kingdom
can find expression in your life even while you
live in this sinful world because by my grace
by my power through the cleansing of my blood you
and i can live on this earth and yet we can live
by principles that are not earthly where is the
kingdom of god it's here it's in you it's in me
12 42 loma linda should be a reflection of the
kingdom of god somebody say amen andrews ought
to be a reflection of the kingdom of god my home
should be a reflection of the kingdom of god yours
when a basketball game is played here we should
see the kingdom of god where is it it's right here
and so in the lord's prayer jesus said after this
man i pray our father which art in heaven hallowed
be thy name what does the rest say thy kingdom
we must long for the world that is governed by
the principles of righteousness thy kingdom come
we are sick of sin we are sick of the principles
of the world now run and dominated by the devil
we must desire and long for and yearn for and pray
and ache for the kingdom of god because it is a
kingdom of righteousness and the righteousness
is defined in the flesh by the life of jesus
christ and in written form in the ten commandments
and so jesus says seek ye first the kingdom of
god seek ye first that lifestyle that through
and through is characterized by righteousness
now you're a member of the kingdom of god
its principles come from above you think
they show movies in heaven don't answer me
i'm going back to the question do you think
movies are shown in heaven whether they are
rated curated or x-rated they are not shown there
god will show a movie he will one of these days
when he comes back because before god destroys all
sinners they have to see the lives they have led
they have to see god was fair that's why paul
says in philippians 2 every knee shall bow
and everything shall confess jesus christ is lord
before god destroys the sinners they must confess
lord you were right and somehow he will show them
their lives where the screen will be i don't know
but if you believe the kingdom of god
includes movies then that's your belief
this kingdom functions on principles
that are precisely in conformity
with the very character of god
and it was kept the law the ark in the most holy
compartment of that tent the most holy compartment
and i say again the entire reason for the
tank was the ten commandments in that ark
the throne a righteous throne the scepter
the symbol of rule a scepter of righteousness
and jesus came to call men
and women into this kingdom
in this kingdom there is love one for the other
one of the great tragedies of bible study or
modern religion is that people make a difference
between the law and love not understanding
that the law is an expression of love and the
highest expression of love is obedience to god
so you've actually got preachers and
christians telling people love don't obey
that's like saying don't breathe and live
let me lower the decibels of my voice i
scream at you a lot you must forgive me
people who preach have a painful ache inside
any preacher listening to me will know exactly
what i say you've got a pain inside and
you ease it only by delivering god's word
i'm telling you it is only eased when you get a
chance to deliver god's word but we must remember
we are saying flesh and blood so i lower the
decibels of my voice at forties uh 14 minutes
to one and let me appeal to your heart first
come back tonight this is only half the sermon
come back tonight i am going to tell you something
that perhaps you've never thought of but if you
will receive it the way we live our lives will
change i have told you before god functions on
the basis of principles have i said that before
have i told you before god is a god of procedure
god's not a process god's a god of order i will
express that tonight in context of the kingdom
of god this kingdom of righteousness and so
god said to moses let them make me a sanctuary
that i might dwell among them god dwells in
an environment of righteousness he brings it
and he dwells in it that's why sin had to
be wiped away washed away by the blood of
christ because god does not want to dwell in
an unrighteous environment he wants to dwell
where it is righteous where all that
he is is reflected in all that we do
righteous professors whose consciences
are clear when they return the papers
that they marked righteous students whose
consciences are clear that they did not cheat
righteous everybody whose consciences are
clear because the conscience is viewed
through the lens of god standard of right and
wrong the commandments and it detects no spots
no stains no aberrations and all that
means it is the very character of god
i didn't say the substance of god that's jesus
i said the very character of god i want a place
in god's kingdom now and when he comes to
make it the entire system of this world
i want to remain in god's kingdom and
i publicly say father by your grace
and the blood of your son jesus christ i renew
my commitment to you receive me as a citizen
of this kingdom how many will say father my
desire is to live in the kingdom of god can i
see your hands god bless you will you stand with
me 12 minutes to one we have two minutes to pray
god bless you remember if you have the cards
fill them out we want to know if you need
bible studies you need prayer you want to have
a one-on-one with me because i'll be here five
days after sabbath just seeing people my great
joy is preaching and meeting one on one i want
you to leave this place thinking am i a citizen
of the kingdom of god am i a law abiding citizen
you know i love policemen i would not
live in a town where there no police
policemen don't bother me at all you know why i
try to keep the law policemen are a blessing to me
but for the law breaker you better run on high
they become a curse god's law is like that
but we can be citizens of the kingdom and that's
what we have stood to say every head bowed every
eye closed father in the name of jesus we come to
you and we say make us by the blood of your son
citizens of the kingdom of god which is a kingdom
of righteousness a kingdom of justice a kingdom of
love father remove from our hearts any principles
of the enemy that may have led our lives and let
the principles of your kingdom from top to
bottom control every facet of our lives give
us a love for these principles i pray because
one day you are coming to establish this kingdom
all over this world and we want to be
a part so now day by day let us live
as faithful citizens of this kingdom i pray that
the principles of right and justice may be seen
in our lives i offer this prayer in jesus name
and for his sacred all god's people stay with me
amen you